director luke bason's the fifth element
has it all set in the 23rd century the
1997 summer blockbuster features an
intriguing storyline about an ex-special
forces major and current cab driver
corbin dallas who alongside the
orange-haired humanoid lilu embarks on a
mission to obtain stones needed to save
earth from certain doom
it touts strong performances from its
incredible cast intense fight scenes and
great comedic lines
every five minutes in something obama's
happening i'm leaving
perhaps the most iconic scene in the
film though is the one centered around
the alien diva plava naguna's operatic
performance
she sings a unique arrangement of el
doce suno from the opera lucino de
la mamore performed by inva meula in the
movie the blue skin diva enraptures not
only the scene's fictional audience but
also the real life audience watching the
film from the vocals to the visuals
floating around the diva to the way she
looks it's hard not to be captivated by
the sequence
looking back a big question is raised
who is the actual performer beneath the
unforgettable blue makeup the tentacles
sprouting from her head and the
intricate black neck piece and matching
wristbands
it's not the singer mula her name is
mywen lebesco
before she dawned the blue face and body
paint an elaborate alien costume to play
the diva plava naguna in the fifth
element
maiwan had been working as an actress
for several years she appeared
in her first credited role when she was
just five years old playing a character
called prune in the 1981 film next year
if all goes well
my wen then played the kid in director
jean becker's award-winning 1983 drama
one deadly summer which was a big hit in
france at the time
from there my wine appeared in several
french films over the next decade
including 1986's state of grace luc
besson began a relationship with my
wedding during this time when she was
just 15 years old and he was in his
early 30s
my wife and best song met when she was
only 12. four years later on january 3rd
1993
maiwan gave birth to their daughter
shauna besson in 1994 my when portrayed
the blonde babe in bessel's film
lyon the professional starring
jean-raino as the titular french
assassin and natalie portman his 12 year
old matilda lando
whom lyon hesitantly takes in after her
family is killed
my when's call girl character isn't in
the movie for long she appears for a
brief moment near the beginning of the
movie
my when was only 21 years old when the
fifth element hit theaters in may 1997
at the time she was married to luke
bessol who asked her to play the part of
the diva
surprisingly enough maiwan initially
declined that she believed that working
together wouldn't be great for their
marriage
my wife explained in an interview that
she gave best son an ultimatum
either you choose you are with me and we
don't work together
either we're not together and okay
i would do the deeper in the same
interview mylen explained that besson
accepted the rejection and cast a german
model in the role
however the model never showed up for a
scheduled costume fitting and makeup
test in london
and no one could reach her or her agent
seeing bestsellers stress
my wen offered to step in and she began
filming two days later
it seems that maywen's worries about how
working together might impact her and
her husband's marriage were
founded she and besson ultimately ended
their marriage during production
a time in which basal had left my win
for mila yovovich who played lilu in the
film
bison yovovich married in 1997 later
divorcing in 1999 after she famously
appeared in the title role of his film
the message or the story of joan of arc
in positive news maiwan's career has
soared since playing the diva
from 1997 to 2020 she notched over 20
roles in film and television maywennis
appeared in short films like kokietz and
eight rue charles she was featured in
the tv movie luis sure various films
including high tension
love is the perfect crime the price of
success all-inclusive and the man in the
hat
and also in several series like nestor
burma and kamara cafe
myuen began directing writing and
producing in 2004.
her first project as director was the
2004 short film i'm an actress in which
she played isabelle from there she
directed produced and starred in 2006's
pardon
moi she then directed and appeared in
2009's all about actresses
by wayne's third full-length feature
poulets which she wrote directed and
starred in was nominated for 13 cesar
awards
which are considered the french oscars
including best original screenplay best
director and best film
she received similar accolades for her
next film mon wow my wine's most recent
original project was dna
which she directed co-wrote with matthew
demi and starred in as the character
nezh it premiered in french cinemas on
may 19th 2021 after debuting at the
dovur film festival in september 2020.
beyond her professional career my wine
is also mother to daughter shauna who's
now a photographer and actress and son
diego whom she had with her second
husband jeannie blefue
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movie stars are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one